After witnessing the "violent rage" shown by babies...
...whenever deprived of an item they considered their own,...
...Jean Piaget, a founding father of child psychology,...
...observed something profound about human nature:...
...our sense of ownership emerges incredibly early.
Why are we so clingy?
There's a well-established phenomenon in psychology known as the endowment effect,...
...where we value items much more highly just as soon as we own them.
Part of this has to do with how quickly we form connections...
...between our sense of self and the things we consider ours.
That can even be seen at the neural level.
In one experiment, neuroscientists scanned participants' brains...
...while they allocated various objects...
...either to a basket labeled "Mine" or another labeled "Alex's."
When participants subsequently looked at their new things,...
...their brains showed more activity in a region that usually flickers into life...
...whenever we think about ourselves.
What remains to be seen today...
...is how the nature of our relationship with our possessions...
...will change with the rise of digital technologies.
Many have forecast the demise of physical books and music,...
...but for now at least, this seems premature.
Perhaps there will always be something uniquely satisfying...
...about holding an object in our hands and calling it our own.